foreign
podcast where we discuss what it means
to live a meaningful life with less my
name is Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists we're here with malabama hi
everybody TK Coleman let's go oh man
coming up today on this free public
minimal episode we're talking to a
listener about the pain of clinging we
also have a question about why do you
refuse to do advertisements on your
podcast then our lightning round segment
a live stream question and a listener
tip for you you can check out the full
two hour maximal edition of episode 395
where we answer five times the questions
and we dive deep into several simple
living segments that private podcast
episode is out right now at patreon.com
the minimalists your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free because say with me
y'all
advertisements suck yes they do let's
start with our callers if you have
question or a comment for our show give
us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice recording
to podcasts at the minimalists.com our
first question today is from Gabby
my name is Gabby I was born and raised
in San Francisco I recently won a case
to keep my rent controlled unit at
twelve hundred dollars a month for a
three bedroom unit
and one of the most expensive cities in
the world
um I have new landlords that try to
raise the rent to about five thousand
dollars a month
um
so I've been battling a case that has
lasted about a year and a half
I have back rent that is owed
um
and I need help in deciding whether or
not I should stay or if I should leave
this household is also my childhood home
that I grew up in I am now 30 years old
I have experienced some childhood trauma
here and also recent harassment from my
landlords which has been very stressful
for me
I have sort of become a hoarder in the
past year and I know that needed a lot
of these Go including possibly uprooting
and leaving and starting over
someplace new
more importantly I have to decide if I
want to negotiate a buyout or keep
living here and possibly get a roommate
and uh makes some money myself
I think it would be cool if you could do
a YouTube video about this topic and
give me some advice on how I can use
minimalism in helping me navigate
through this decision
Gabby I hear this unbearable weight in
your voice and I know that quite often
holding on to something that no longer
serves us creates and amplifies that
weight makes it heavier TK where do you
want to start with this one yeah you
know when I first heard Gabby say I've
got a lot of childhood memories here I
thought oh man this is going to be tough
this is going to be tough you know hard
to leave those places behind but then
when you mention what kind of childhood
memories those were I thought oh
it's going to be tough to keep staying
there you know so how can minimalism
help well minimalism is about looking at
all of your options putting them on the
table and assessing them in terms of how
they relate to your highest values one
of the questions we talk about a lot on
this show is those powerful three words
compared to what how do you see your
life how do you want to feel and where
are you now and how does that relate to
that to that answer to that question so
I think there are three questions to
always ask and that is the the places
where I am the things I possess
um are they taking me where I want to be
are they anchoring me in some place I
want to stay or are they holding me back
from some place I want to be I'd start
there you listed a few options and I
would I would highly encourage you
to um
facilitate this decision-making process
by by kind of looking at what the
possibilities are so you mentioned for
instance negotiating a bio
um it sounds like that's a thought in
your mind but no steps have been taken
in that taken in that direction I would
maybe ask a few questions to see what
does a buyout even look like because you
may find out some information that make
you say oh hell no I'm not I'm not
agreeing to a buyout at that price or it
might be a better deal than you might
think another thing is even if you
decide to stay there's nothing wrong
with taking a look around at the options
that exist right now sometimes it's hard
to make a decision about leaving or
staying if you have nothing to compare
it to so if you can get out there take a
look at some other options you might
find something at a at a feasible price
that makes you say hey you know what
being able to move into this place right
now compared to staying around fighting
and dealing with all this drama it might
help but if you're just looking at it in
the abstract it's going to be really
difficult to make a decision and so I
would take a look at what my options are
ask some questions and get some of the
insights that I need from that yeah yeah
it sounds like there's a couple things
going on so she talked about being a
little bit of a hoarder and she talked
about this run problem
um speaking to the rent problem and the
landlords putting myself in your
position man like you might win this
case which
1200 a month for a three bedroom
apartment in San Francisco is like
hitting the lottery that's crazy
um that's really awesome if you win the
case though
the I can only imagine how Petty the
landlords will start to be
so
um that's something to consider in the
sense of like you may win this case but
just know that the relationship that
you're that you have with your landlord
is going to be a very
um contentious relationship so yeah what
that's going to look like I have no idea
as far as the horde goes
um yeah I mean start with the
spontaneous combustion rule I mean
there's there's a there's 16 rules that
Josh and I wrote about you could just
pick one of them and kind of start there
if you want to start um uh whittling
down on your horde so the spontaneous
combustion rule you pick up any item in
your house and you look at it and you
ask yourself hey what would I do if
they're saying spontaneously combusted
and if your instant reaction is like oh
I would feel so sad and I would have to
go out and get another one or oh man
that thing is irreplaceable and yeah I
would really be devastated and don't get
rid of it but if your thought is like
meh I don't know I probably wouldn't
replace it like that's a sign that you
could probably let that thing go if you
do end up moving though
um that's a great time to really go
through all your stuff I'll tell you
um yeah the packing party is great so
you could bring everything to your new
home and kind of unpack things as you
need it but I'll be honest like getting
rid of the stuff while you're packing it
up is so much easier
um Mariah and I have started to use this
rule um and you might have talked about
this before is there a space for it so
it's like we got um we went to Sedona
and we got some crystals you know as as
you do in Sedona
so don't Arizona it's a long if you live
without crystals you're not allowed back
no uh her uh there's a friend of the fan
a friend of her family's that works at a
crystal shop we went there beautiful
stuff like amazing amazing crystals and
she gave us like some gifts but like
they just are kind of like sitting and
I'm like hey can we get rid of these and
Mariah's like no I you know I really
like the crystals and you know we'll use
them Someday I'm like is there a space
for them like right now where we can put
them to like display them and uh we've
kind of been approaching conversations
that way um I like this is there a home
for your things in your new home oh yeah
it's good if you're going to be moving
and so in a way you're doing a packing
party twice you're you're actually using
some of those rules the seasonality rule
the the 2020 rule the just in case rule
the spontaneous combustion rule maybe
you're doing the 30-day minimalism game
which by the way you can download that
free ebook it's 16 rules for a living
with less we call it the minimalist rule
book The minimalists.com
rulebook anyway you can do that as
you're packing everything up but then
when you get to the new place it's like
a second chance to go through these
things again yeah it's almost like this
I have a reverse osmosis filter on my
water at home and it's not just one
filter it has multiple filters right and
you're doing this with your stuff you're
the first filter is using some of these
boundaries these rules that you set up
for yourself and by the way when TK and
Ryan and I call them rules they're not
really rules they are boundaries that
are adjustable for your life so
seasonality for you might be 120 days or
it might be 30 days you get to pick the
boundary that's a appropriate for you
let me say this though Gabby because
you're going through a really difficult
time and there's an unbearable weight
that if you continue to carry it will
just become more and more unbearable
here's the good news you've learned
something about yourself throughout this
process you've learned to Bear the
unbearable oh yeah it feels as though oh
I couldn't do this anymore but at this
point it's no longer serving you you're
gonna have to make a difficult decision
yeah but here's the thing about a
difficult decision it's not actually
that difficult when you put it here on
the table here's what you're choosing
between you can have lots of certainty
and misery if you stay where you are
right now
or
you can let go you can have some
uncertainty but in that uncertainty you
can find the joy in your new life you
can only do that by letting go it's true
that this home may have once served you
when you were a child and even last year
maybe it served you really well um
when I was 22 years old I got my dream
job
I have nightmares about that job today
why is that well the reason I have
nightmares about is because I outgrew it
I got to an ending and I continued to
hold on to it
and that dream job turned into a
nightmare on a long enough timeline all
of our dreams if we cling to them they
turn into nightmares and that's why
we're talking today about the pain of
clinging before we started recording
Ryan said but the inverse of that is the
joy of letting go there's the joy within
the uncertainty we call it the fear of
missing out but really it's the joy of
missing out here's the truth Gabby
you're never going to go back to the way
things were that's the LIE of nostalgia
you got what you needed out of this
place but you can't possibly go back you
won't continue getting what you once got
from it that's a lie if you keep driving
staring in the rear view you are going
to crash yeah I love what you brought up
about your dream job because what
happened was the same thing that
happened to me where you're so attached
you're clinging to that paycheck that
like really really big salary and if
you're clinging to it just because of
the financial piece of it
um you can only hold on so long and if
your only reason Gabby for staying in
that apartment is because it's so cheap
if that's the only reason
um
I think you could probably hold on for
only so long
yeah and you know even with respect to
the certainty I don't even know if
that's present you know staying where
you are and having some certainty
because you've got the back rent to pay
you've got the uncertainty of how the
case is going to unfold the uncertainty
about how long this is going to go
anytime we say we want something we
should always ask ourselves
um how much pain am I willing to bear in
order to have what it is I want so I
might want something but that doesn't
mean I'm willing to wait around for an
hour for it or a year for it so how long
are you willing to fight that might be
something worth thinking about if this
court case drags on for five years six
years seven years is that worth it
because by the time you kind of know
what's going on part of your life is
over you can't get that time back so
those are some important things to think
about absolutely like if you don't have
a plan if you don't have like a a plan b
or a plan a like right now she's in
limbo so I could see where after a year
and a half being in limbo how
frustrating it is so
um yeah the the the maybe the best place
to start for you Gabby is to start
forming a plan as if you were to move
um and at least yeah at least look at
something different but no plan at all
in in limbo like that's definitely uh
that's going to be pretty miserable
letting go is difficult Gabby letting go
is so difficult but you know what is
more difficult
holding on to something that is dragging
you in a direction in which you don't
want to travel and that's what's
happening right now you're holding on to
something from the past and it's no
longer serving you and if you hold on
tightly and you're unwilling to let go
whether it's a material possession it's
a childhood home it is a memory it is a
relationship if you're holding on You're
simply going to get dragged Gabby I'd
love to send you a copy of our book
everything that remains coming up on the
10-year anniversary Ryan oh my goodness
we moved to a cabin in the middle of
nowhere in 2012 to write the first draft
of this it came out January 1st of 2014
and in this book everything that remains
it's really the story of me and Ryan
letting go of our past and the
difficulties of letting go of that past
and getting Dragged In directions we
didn't necessarily know we were going to
get dragged and getting Dragged In
directions we didn't want to get dragged
in letting go of this corporate career
letting go of our homes letting go of
our material possessions letting go of
our identities this book is ultimately
about letting go of your identity so you
can form the identity of the person you
want to become because right now your
past is the enemy of your future and so
let's send you a copy of everything that
remains if you like our podcast I think
you'll enjoy the audiobook version of
that book or if you want the book book
or the ebook version would be happy to
send those to you as well jewels on
YouTube had a question I thought this
was a perfect time for this question why
don't you consider the constant plugging
of your own private podcast as
advertising especially since it's behind
a paywall well I want to make a
distinction between marketing and
advertising because I get it if you say
well you're talking about patreon isn't
that an advertisement you're using that
term in a way that I wouldn't use the
term advertising I want to get really
specific about what we're talking about
there's a long essay on our website I'll
put a link to it in the show notes it's
called can we have an honest
conversation about advertisements and
there's one short section in here about
marketing versus advertising and here's
what it says the flip side of
advertising isn't the absence of
communication
it's marketing in his book The mindset
of marketing your music Derek sivers
writes don't confuse the word marketing
with advertising announcing spamming or
giving away branded crap really
marketing just means being considerate
marketing means making it easy for
people to notice you relate to you
remember you and tell their friends
about you what sivers is describing here
is the most honest form of marketing
informing people without manipulating or
bothering them
at its ethical Zenith marketing
considers the needs and points of view
of an audience and works hard to meet
those needs by connecting the creators
with consumers in an authentic way
in neutral terms marketing is an unpaid
endorsement Often by the Creator herself
communicated directly to an audience
who's eager to learn more about the
product or service when done well this
is what Seth Godin describes as
permission marketing the privilege not
the right but the privilege of
delivering anticipated personal and
relevant messages to people who actually
want to get them it is possible to
engage in world-class marketing without
spending a penny on Advertising true
both advertising and marketing are forms
of promotion both allow creators to
present their goods and services to a
group of people and when executed poorly
even well-intentioned marketing can be
Overkill like advertisements not all
marketing messages are created equal
hmm
I don't I this feels like a like a
gotcha question am I saying that wrong I
would just look at it and say this
person doesn't understand what they mean
by what but what we mean by
advertisements yeah I don't want someone
else to pay me in a way that takes away
my ability to talk about things that I
want to talk about that restricts my
speech I think that's part of it but
also I don't want to clutter my
creations with someone else's products
and services however if we create
something be it a book like one of our
books like a lot of people use things or
we have the minimalist private podcast
these are things that we create or the
minimalist rulebook which is free you
can download it for free on our website
these are products that we have created
that we believe in that we enjoyed
creating and we've built a trust with an
audience so that and we've added value
immense value to an audience so that
when we create something and we give
them the option we don't force it on to
them we don't try to manipulate them but
we present sent it to them and say hey
look look what we created I think about
some of my favorite creators someone
like Rob Bell anytime he writes a new
book not only do I want to get him on
the podcast but I pre-ordered that book
immediately and I would actually be
insulted if he refused to tell people
about his new creation yeah I would feel
like he was depriving me of the thing
that I want to read or listen to and so
yes please communicate it to me in a way
that's not beating me over the head with
it but it's letting me know what you've
got going on yeah yeah and there's a
difference too between you using your
platform that you created to let the
people who choose to listen to you
know about the things that you are
creating right there's a difference
between that and saying I'm going to
take a paycheck from somebody else to
promote a product that they created that
I may or may not believe in and in
exchange for that I'm going to give them
the rights to manage some aspect of my
content thus affecting the experience
for my audience there's a difference
between those two things and I think
that's what you're getting at but when
when uh Angel's asking a question I want
to ask you I'd love to hear both of you
all answer this because I have heard
this this take as well you know I accept
these advertisements
because I'm for the people and I and I
want to be I want the people to be able
to have it for free and so by accepting
advertisements you know and this big fat
check that comes with it by accepting
advertisements because you do make way
more on advertisements than what we make
but um by accepting these advertisements
everybody can participate and I'm not
discriminating I'm making it universally
available what's your response to that
yeah that's true
um you're making it universally
available in the same way that if I go
to LACMA and they charge me fifteen
dollars to get in now would I prefer
that experience but every time I go to a
painting there's a 30 second ad in front
of the painting or maybe they just paint
a McDonald's logo or Burger King logo or
a me undies logo on the painting itself
would I pref which one would I prefer
and I think some people would say I
would prefer to go this route and so
this isn't a moral stance that we're
taking here
I don't like advertisements I never turn
on a podcast and say man I wish this had
more advertisements now on episode 400
of this podcast I am going to talk about
I finally found an advertisement that
didn't that I actually liked I wouldn't
say it didn't offend me most of them
don't offend me I just don't like them
the same way that I'm grossed out by
oysters I don't enjoy oysters and so I
don't eat them and the same is true with
podcasts I have unsubscribed from so
many podcasts and YouTube channels
because they incorporate ads into their
Creations I would much rather read a
book like the book I'm going to talk
about here on our added value segment
imagine if I got could get this book for
free but every three pages there was an
advertisement in here right I would
strongly dislike that now someone else
might say I like having that option
wonderful I like having the option of no
ads yeah uh first off I asked about the
gotchi question because I tend not to
like respond to these too much because
it seems it just seems like a um like a
snarky thing it doesn't seem and that's
why I was asking if I was interpreting
it correctly but answering the question
head on I love that you brought up the
LACMA so the LACMA you can get in for
free if you live in L.A
um yep after uh I think it's after four
o'clock don't double check me on that
but if you live in L.A you can get you
can get into LACMA for free but they
also will have special exhibits
sometimes and you got to pay a little
extra money to see the special exhibit
uh for whatever reason whether it's them
you know uh having the resource to keep
the LACMA open to pay the artists of the
special exhibit like whatever the
reasoning is doesn't matter like there
is an extra fee if you want to see the
um the additional exhibits sometimes
so that's how I look at what we do with
the private podcast it's like we give so
much away for free and there is a
special exhibit that we have available
each week that for five bucks a month
ten bucks a month whatever it is you can
uh see that and listen to that special
exhibit that creation that we've gone
way out of our way to create for you and
not only that what I love about the the
the the the the patreon audience we have
like they're invested man so like this
is from YouTube this sounds like a
YouTube comment it doesn't sound like a
one of our patrons commenting that's
right yeah and that's what I really like
about that paywall too is it puts up
this barrier not because we're money
grubbing money grubbers
is that is that grammatically correct
Josh and John anyway
um it's because we are putting up a
barrier because yes we have to pay the
bills but also like we are inviting
people who are really invested in us to
one like give them an opportunity to
support us which I cannot tell you how
many patreons I have signed up for just
because of someone who's added a lot of
value to my life and I just if I can
give them five bucks a month and support
them like that is what I will 100 do
um so hey you're giving people an
opportunity but B like you're really
inviting them to a special Community
where everyone is just as invested as
them into what we what we do here
as I bring this segment to a close uh I
want to just point out one aspect that
you guys don't really talk about a lot
and that is
um
you have way more money to make
by opening the floodgates of advertising
and you have a lot of people some of
whom are very close to you and
influential in your life who want to
have this conversation over and over
again and no matter what your stance is
you know that every quarter you're going
to be sitting down with someone who's
going to be like let me see if I can
sell it to you this time because the
amount of money you would make would go
through the roof compared to what you've
been making sure you accept
advertisements and so what this decision
has really been has been a decision to
say hey we want to create a certain kind
of content that's the privilege of being
a Creator no one forces you to enter the
creation business you enter the creation
business because you've got something
that you want to express and the
fundamental right you have as a Creator
is that decision what art do I want to
make and the decision that you made is
we want to make ad free content and even
though that comes with the risk of
perhaps not being able to pay the bills
we're going to take the chance on an
audience that will appreciate that and
we're gonna ride or die with that and if
we don't make that's cool but this is
the kind of content we want to create
and so far it's worked shout out to the
people that's helped it work but that's
the explanation but guess what that's
just what we think that's just what our
distinction is that's just what we mean
when we use the words but
you don't have to think that way
yourself it's not a defense it's not a
mathematical proof proof it's just an
explanation of how we work and what this
show is all about and um but it's it's
okay to listen to a podcast and say I
don't like that you guys promote your
stuff it's fine that's how you feel
that's that's okay too man you know like
we talked about earlier all the feelings
are are welcome to discussions about
different approaches we take yeah you
could say I don't like that you have
guests on your podcast I don't like that
you answer questions on your podcast
yeah you're allowed to have your own
preferences and so I and I honor and
recognize those preference our
preference is to be a hundred percent
advertisement free dude we got to be an
honor with ourselves like how how crappy
I mean that sounds for us that's selling
out and there's a couple of other ways
we could sell it but that's like the
lowest hanging fruit and like
waking up and not not
being an honor that's one of the worst
feelings in the world to me like when I
wake up and I know that I'm doing
something that morally I don't agree
with like there's no price you could put
on me feeling in honor with myself so
yeah you're you're no longer integral
right yeah meaning you are separate from
the person that you want to be yeah it
yeah I was just gonna uh say on top of
it like I love
I love like being
the example and like hey look when you
put money first it's it is it's a very
bad road to choose to go down if you're
putting money first and like we're
living that and I hope people see that
not because I want to be put on a
pedestal because I hope it inspires them
to be like you know what sometimes like
it money needs always in the always in
the car but sometimes like maybe just
put in the back seat because yeah we
don't pretend it doesn't exist either
right don't say it's last on the list in
fact you know we have a whole team of
people here we make sure that they get
paid every single month and as a result
one of the ways that we do that the
biggest way that we do that is we have a
private podcast that you can support
patreon.com the minimalist wait you guys
are getting paid
oh
Ryan what time is it it's my favorite
time it's time for the lightning round
where we answer your questions from Tick
Tock yes indeed you can follow the
minimalists on Tick Tock Instagram
Facebook and Twitter at the minimalist
during our lightning round we each have
60 seconds to answer your question with
a short shareable less than 140
character response we put the text to
these minimal maxims in the show notes
over at the minimalists.com podcast so
you can copy and share our pithy answers
on social media if you'd like looks like
today's question is from Nate no one can
make you happy is such a BS statement
how does that help someone who is
already lonely
so what Nate is responding to to give
you all some context here there was a
video that we put up on our Tick Tock
account where we talked about how no one
has the power to make you happy no one
has the power to make you upset either
you get to decide whether or not you are
upset whether or not you are happy and
these things around us they can amplify
what's going on inside us but that
person or that thing or that Community
or that relationship or that experience
isn't what is making you happy only you
make you happy let's get 60 seconds on
the clock for my good friend Ryan
Nicodemus all right uh my pit the answer
is this
happiness is not a currency
and I made the mistake for so long
looking at happiness as like the
ultimate currency and every day I would
ask myself how happy am I am I living a
happy life oh I'm not so happy today I
got I'm low on that currency I need to
go find happiness oh that person in my
life how much happiness are they giving
me oh they're not giving me enough I
should probably move on to to someone
else or bring someone else into my life
that is a Chase and if you put happiness
first it's like putting money first it
is a ephemeral resource that is not
going to uh buy you a life well lived
you know it gives you a life well lived
is living a life well lived living a
meaningful life and when you do that all
of the happiness and the good feelings
is a byproduct of that oh so good so
good TK Colin what do you got for us
no one can make you content without your
consent
a good partner can help enhance your
already existing state of Happiness they
can complement your already existing
commitment to cultivating happiness
but what they cannot do is make you
happy in spite of yourself that's
neither fair to them nor feasible for
you so if you're not in a relationship
and you want to be in a relationship
you've got two options you can say I'm
gonna wait until I find a great
relationship before I give myself
permission to be happy or I'm going to
pursue the relationship that I want but
I'm going to create a little bit of
happiness as best as I can along the way
that first option if you say yes to that
then you make it difficult to attract
the right kind of person and you make it
easy to attract the wrong kind of person
but if you exercise that second option
you not only make it easier to attract
the right kind of person but you make it
easier to work the relationship well if
you find them thank you so much for not
making me follow TK I appreciate that
that was really nice of me
well I got something pithy for you all
y'all ready for this yes here we go
it is not wise to lend your happiness to
others and then beg them to give it back
to you yeah
too often I say oh you're going to make
me happy
but I'm already happy I was born happy
and I'm allowing you to take that away
from me no one can make you happy also
no one can make you unhappy no one can
make you angry no one can complete you
no one can fulfill you no one can make
you better
and so why lend your happiness to your
friends to your family to your
co-workers or to people you dislike on
social media why lend your happiness to
them and say please please give me my
happiness back
that is a recipe for misery
I did it under 60 seconds yes we can
talk yeah let's talk about a little bit
more so what's interesting I love what
you said here Josh that's like that's
great man lending your happiness out and
then asking for it back
um if a relationship is started
out of one trying to be happy and they
bring someone into their life telling
themselves like okay now I can be happy
is it's not as powerful as like someone
who is living that meaningful life who's
who's living a life well lived and they
are already happy and then someone else
is drawn
to that person and their happiness if
you show up to a relationship incomplete
that relationship will never complete
you yes I'm thinking about my own
relationships in my home with my wife
and my ten-year-old daughter and the
other day my daughter left her book bag
and a camping bag on the floor in the
middle of the hallway and she'll do that
from time to time and not pay much
attention and I will of course what I'll
get upset and I'll say oh look what you
have done you've taken away my happiness
but of course she didn't and even if she
did that intentionally to try to make me
unhappy it's still my choice as to
whether or not I accept that unhappiness
or that discontent from her but also I
can look at that and I can recognize
like oh
it is not up to me to be fulfilled to be
satisfied externally through if my
daughter does all of the right things in
the right sequence then I'm allowed to
be happy if my wife does all the right
things I look at our refrigerator and if
it was just me living alone it would
look a whole lot more organized inside
our refrigerator it would look like a
magazine ad generally but that's just
because I have OCD however it's not my
wife saying you know what
huh I'm going to make you unhappy
no
my getting upset about that
is up to me and it's also up to me to me
to decide to not be upset by that to
Simply Let It Go
yeah one of the things this makes me
think about is how in in many
conversations on self-help philosophy
the Paradox is that it's not very
helpful if we don't allow space for the
colloquial use of speech and so so many
of these answers depend on what a person
means by the terms they use so in the
way we're talking about it no one can
make you happy because what we mean by
that is no one can force you to feel Joy
and spite of the choices you make you
have to cooperate with another person's
efforts to inspire joy in you it is also
true that when many people informally
say things like they make me happy what
they really mean is that when I am with
this person I feel a lot of joy and it's
something that's a lot more casual and
so can someone make you happy well if
what you mean is can I find great joy
and great fulfillment in the presence of
another absolutely you sure can but can
someone make me happy if what you mean
by that is can someone lift me out of my
depression lift me out of my despondency
in spite of any decisions that I make no
no one can do that for you it's got to
be a collaboration it's got to be a
process for co-creation another person
can help you they can inspire you but
you've got to show up for yourself as
well yeah when when he said something
about or when he's talking about someone
making him happy
um it's really about like does that
person enhance
like that's I think that's what he's
saying like this you know person in my
life could enhance my happiness but the
problem is that
if you aren't happy right now like if
you're waking up every day like I'm
miserable and then you bring someone in
and maybe it doesn't enhance your
happiness and maybe it truly does like
give you purpose every day and you're
like oh I'm so glad I have this person
in my life
man you're still like you're giving them
your happiness and you're making them
responsible for your happiness not very
empowering I'm not loving either
in order for me to be happy you have to
be there that's a burden man that is
yeah yeah just I I Echo what you're
saying that's a lot of pressure to put
on another person that's a lot of
responsibility to throw in their hands
oh man yeah I really because Nate Nate
sounds lonely
so what TK how do you how do you like
how would you address the loneliness
aspect of this question
I I don't know if I share that that
perception of Nate okay I I don't know
what Nate sounds like to me it sounds
like it's just I'm taking it as a
question that says hey
what you said here sounds like BS to me
but yet I'm extending enough charity and
open-mindedness to you to say I'd like
to hear you reconcile the contradiction
yeah I think we did that well yeah
absolutely we're gonna check out the
patreon live stream here in a moment but
first real quick for right here right
now here's one thing that's going on in
the life of the minimalists our good
friend podcast Sean is graduating yeah
this gentleman podcast Sean man what a
stalwart if you're watching a the video
version of the podcast you'll see a
photo I had Sean send this to me uh this
weekend this is from 2014. Ryan and I
were on our third or fourth tour at this
point look at those naive young men
hundred cities we're in Dayton Ohio he
brought his daughter Gabby who at the
time I think she was 10 early she's
about my daughter's age which makes me
think my daughter's gonna be in her 20s
in a blink of an eye man and so we were
in a Dayton Ohio this is a dvac which is
is they actually moved to the Dayton
arcade recently but we were downtown
Dayton for an awesome tour stop there
and we had uh Sean Harding podcast Sean
this is before he started working with
us as the minimalists so we talked about
this a bit last week on the private
podcast I wanted to bring this forward
for the public version of the podcast
just to honor Sean and recognize them
we've known Sean for a couple decades
now yeah we worked together in the
corporate world and he was the most
organized person he did all the
inventory for our retail stores and he
managed inventory there and then
eventually he got promoted he was
teaching as well he's also an English
teacher a public school teacher for a
while and um as we started growing the
minimals started growing on its own we
never intended to grow this into a
business even eventually a few years in
we actually had to turn it into a
business it was a Blog for a period of
time and then a thousand people were
showing up at our tour stops and it was
like I guess this is a business now and
so while we were on this tour we
actually had Professor Sean who's here
now he's taken over a lot of the audio
engineering duties because last year if
you are a long time patreon subscriber
you saw the conversation that we did
with podcast Sean he moved back to
Montana and uh they're actually looking
at moving East now it's somewhere in the
the Carolinas possibly to be closer to
family and so while he's graduating from
the minimalist we're always going to
keep an open door for him because when
we first started working together it was
because we kept looking for someone like
Sean Harding and every time Rhino like
we would interview someone and we want
to bring someone on board we could
really use someone like Sean Harding and
eventually Ryan comes to me one day and
he says you know who's like Sean Harding
who Sean Harding
and so we dragged him out to Montana oh
we wooed him so much man kayaks Lakes
mountains it was awesome and uh we have
worked with him now since 2014 so for
the last decade we've worked with
podcast John and while he's graduating
from the minimalist he'll always have a
home here we leave the door open for him
in the future who knows maybe he and his
family will come out to to California
and we'll have another chapter but he's
moving on right now he's letting go of
this and we're letting go together so
that he can move on direction that he
wants to move and we fully support him
in that not just that but we honor him
and we recognize him because he's been
an amazing part of this podcast if you
enjoy the way this podcast sounds and
the way that it's edited and also he's
been our fact totem he's been our tour
manager he has been so much for the
minimalist he's been our director of
operations uh responsible for emails and
and customer Communications and editing
books and all kinds of amazing things
for the minimalists we're so grateful
for that oh my goodness this and I am
especially grateful for that smile that
he has oh my God how dare him have a
better smile than the three of us in
that picture there's so much joy oh my
God yes like that is yeah he's got a
great smile so I'm definitely not
letting go of podcast Sean
um I'm not letting you go brother uh
that's my Catholic brother on a
minimalist but you know I remember uh
just being on a tour with you guys
and um Sean and I would often just stay
up late in the hotel lobbies and just
talk I remember our time together and uh
yeah those are some of the some of the
best moments man so
um we'll miss having you around this
space but my brother me and you will
continue to stay linked man yeah and
when I say letting go we're not letting
go of him and I think it's important to
recognize with any relationship as
relationships change and that could be a
relationship with your job it could be a
relationship with your friends it could
be a relationship with your things
you can move on and you can let go of
the way that things were in fact in
order to move on you have to let go of
holding on of clinging because that
creates that pain that the pain of
clinging you have to let go of that
clinging in order to move on to whatever
the next chapter is going to be I got an
r b lyric just coming in I don't know if
this is uh Brian McKnight or if it's
just me and my subconscious but the r b
lyric is
what could we be if we weren't bowed to
what we used to be
music just queuing up right that's all
because like when he was saying that I
was thinking about how grateful I am for
all the amazing memories that I have
wish on and uh on tour and you know I
mean we got to go to Australia together
I mean and just nest for that matter too
like it's so wonderful like to have
those memories and I don't have any
souvenirs or trinkets to remind me of
those memories they all live right here
and yeah of course pictures like this
remind me yeah well I'll share this one
with you
podcast Sean we love you we appreciate
you we're grateful for you many more
years much more Health to come by the
way he's uh he seems to be doing really
great right now in in Montana I'm
looking forward to figuring out what
that next chapter is for him as he moves
on we'll check out the patreon live
stream here I'm Alabama real quick what
do you got for us here's a question from
Marcos I have everything I need and more
but I'm anxious all the time I have no
idea what needs to change how do I
figure out where to start letting go
hmm
anxiety this is like this resonates with
me so much because I think uh in my late
20s when I had everything I ever wanted
when I was making a lot of money
um I think I had that Pursuit because of
the anxiety that I always felt and
thinking that if I could obtain as much
as possible that that would go away and
that I would be happy
and when it comes to the anxiety for me
it's really about
um it's like holding space for it and
examining it rather than me letting it
control me so why do you feel anxious is
it because you have too much stuff is
did he say too much stuff we just had
every said he has everything he needs
yeah yeah which which maybe usually when
we have everything we need we get there
through excess and excess becomes a
disease where it's more and more and
more and so now I have enough but I also
have what more than enough yeah yeah I
mean that that that anxiety is a symptom
Marcos and
I would examine why you have that
symptom if it is because of the stuff
great maybe it has to do with like my
anxiety comes from childhood drama and
I'm so glad that I had like a therapist
kind of help me understand that because
intellectually you could tell me hey
your anxiety comes from childhood trauma
I'd get it but like until I emotionally
connected with it it wasn't until I
could
stare at my anxiety in the face and be
like what do you want what do you want
now like do you really want something or
are you just like freaking out for no
reason I think it's an important point
that anxiety is the symptom and so you
don't want to get rid of the symptom you
want to figure out what is causing that
symptom that's ultimately the only way
to let go yeah absolutely like what I'm
hearing is hey I have everything that I
want but I still don't have the peace
that I thought I would have by now what
do I need to let go I would say what
needs to be released is the narrative
that my peace will come from having
everything that I want or I should have
already been at Peace by now and I think
the good part about having everything
that you want is that you're free from a
lot of the distractions that might
um you know make you feel like you don't
have time to be present with yourself
and to ask yourself these critical
questions I think that's the good part
and I I would encourage you to find a
space and a person
in whom and with whom you can talk this
out I encourage some kind of counselor
some kind of therapy I think you need to
just take some time to process that
anxiety and get under the hood get
underneath that start unpacking it and
seeing what's going on there with your
assumptions your expectations and
whatever other things you have going on
yeah so when I feel anxiety my first
reaction is to be like oh what do I feel
anxious about so I anxiety arises and
then I start looking for problems and
what I've been able to do is I will go
through my today list I will go through
my calendar I'll go through my emails
and I'll be like okay so is there
anything that's pressing right now
because that's what I feel I feel like I
need to be doing something right now and
if all of that is clear like I give
myself permission to stop clinging to
the anxiety because that's what you're
doing you're either clinging or you're
letting go and by the way life is a
series of attachment and detaching
attaching detaching attaching detaching
yeah and if you're not doing that that's
when you're clinging and that's when it
becomes a painful burden Alabama what
else you got for us here's a minimalist
Insight from one of our listeners hey
there Alexis from New York city so
something that has made me think twice
about what I bring into my home is
donating with purpose so as I've been
downsizing I've been leaving all of my
stuff in a bucket on the floor and I've
really been doing my research to try and
find places that'll actually use my
stuff
and you'd be surprised at how hard it is
to find places who will take your stuff
even if it's good stuff
um so in doing all of this work I am
finding meaning and purpose in the
things I'm donating and I'm thinking
twice about what I bring into my home
all right y'all that's our minimal
episode for today we'll see you on
patreon for the full two hour maximal
edition of episode 395 which includes
answers to a bunch more questions
questions like when it comes to clinging
what role does stress play how do I
identify what is clutter and what is
needed in my home should I tolerate my
Angry boss or should I start looking for
a new job plus a million more questions
for the minimalist also this week a
private minimalist home tour from one of
our listeners it is the coolest most
peaceful Lounge room that I've seen in a
long time and much more of less if you
want to hear all that check out the
minimalist private podcast this week
patreon.com the minimalist or click the
link in the description to subscribe to
get your personal link so that our
weekly Maxwell episodes play in your
favorite podcast app you also gain
access to all of our podcast archives
all the way back to episode zero zero
one if you leave here today with just
one message please let it be this
love people
and use things because the opposite
never works thanks for listening y'all
we'll see you next time peace
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed or I bet that you'll be fine
without it
every little